yeah I just don't understand why you
would do that on purpose why would call
yourself content crave it's like saying
I what is confident well it's anything
to be pictures it could be needs it
could be a blog it could be anything
okay so I don't create anything I'm a
storyteller I tell stories so sing
content creators like saying I create
nouns it's not it's it's why would i
choose to say i do even less than what i
do why would I why would I diminish the
name purposely just because content is
came I get it but bad content is not him
so content doesn't mean anything so I
don't use that term I don't say I'm a
content creator you know what I make
content you want to see some of my
content here it is this isn't it great
airs contents shoes are cut no I tell
stories I'm a storyteller and I tell the
stories online that's you don't say hey
do you guys want to go see some content
at the movies would you do that no it's
it's it's stupid terminology that you
wouldn't use real lives so
no show a little pride in your work and
stop calling yourself a noun creator and
just because that's the buzz word or
whatever that's stupid coffee
please God
yeah web celebrity web celebrity is
easily one of the dumbest terms you
could use because to purposely call
yourself like oh I'll cut you some slack
for content creator because everybody
you said you just be like oh yeah I'm a
content creator and it sounds great but
web celebrity is just stupid
because here's life celebrity is saying
that you're famous web celebrity is
quantifying your fame so how famous do
you have to be in the world to call
yourself a celebrity judging by dancing
with the stars not very famous
uh so web celebrity you're dropping it
even lower the wrong because now you're
famous on the web so why you just stop
quantifying who you are and coming up
with ridiculous terms like you're not a
web celebrity you're just called
yourself famous you just sound like a
dick you don't sound like hi I'm who
would walk around going hi I'm a web
celebrity just because it says guru and
expert and all that on your Twitter
bio let me go out the real world try to
say that to people in conversation and
see if it sounds stupid because when
they read it at least when I read it I
think it sounds stupid to call yourself
a content creator or a web this single
effort
it's it's a stop yeah I mean I on the
man karma by oh I say the names of the
TV shows that the caster from and that
is absolutely on purpose because I want
people to know that that it is not a
weapon so it's not a it's it's a story
that's told online with really good
actors here's the other shows they did
that that makes our show look like okay
well these people do this show then they
must not so so they can do that show on
my personal account it says I right
things and say things and make things
and you can also find me at vampire mom
because I write things I say things and
I make this call lack and I could save
storyteller I could say I'm a writer
director editor producer camera operator
sound designer / d / oh god I
just right things and because because
the thing about is I'm not I'm trying to
tell stories i'm not trying to sell
stories and that's because the audience
helps me make stories and so bad so I'm
I talk to people I don't talk to an
industry I don't talk to a factory I
talked to human beings who watch what I
do that's the demographic that I right
or human beings who like what I do I
don't know what gender they are how old
they are
but if they like what I do then they're
my Democrat
you